[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
accès aux soins en finir avec les
déserts médicaux
saviez vous que près d'un tiers de la
population française vit dans un désert
médical
garantir à chacun l'accès aux soins quel
que soit son lieu de résidence tel est
l'objectif de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable
le nombre de médecins généralistes par
rapport à la population a diminué en
moyenne de 1% par an depuis 2000 17
la quasi totalité des territoires manque
de médecins
les inégalités territoriales d'accès aux
soins continuent de se creuser avec des
délais d'attentes de plusieurs mois
voire des renoncements aux soins
dans son rapport publié le 29 mars 2022
bruno rejoint propose des mesures
concrètes pour éviter les effets sévères
de la pénurie de médecins au cours de la
prochaine décennie
afin de promouvoir l'exercice dans les
zones sous denses la commission suggère
de repenser les dispositifs incitatifs à
l'installation des professionnels de
santé et de libérer du temps médical
grâce au recours simplifié aux
assistants médicaux
pour corriger les déséquilibres les plus
flagrants le rapport propose deux
mesures phares
conditionné l'installation dans les
zones sur dotées en médecins à la
cessation d'activité d'un médecin
exerçant la même spécialité et instaurer
un conventionnement sélectif temporaire
c'est à dire réserver le
conventionnement à l'assurance maladie
aux médecins s'installant dans une zone
qui en a besoin
de plus il est indispensable d'accroître
le nombre d'étudiants en médecine
générale est de créer une quatrième
année de troisième cycle pour la
médecine générale ce qui permettrait
l'arrivée de 3900 médecin junior
prioritairement dans les zones sous
denses
le rapport suggère également
d'expérimenter des internats ruraux dans
les zones d'intervention prioritaire
il incite aussi les collectivités
territoriales à créer des guichets
uniques pour qu'elle devienne actrice de
leur attractivité médicale
en matière de gouvernance
le rapport préconise de mieux associer
les élus dans l'organisation de
proximité des soins et de renforcer les
moyens alloués aux délégations
départementales des agences régionales
de santé en leur octroyant des
compétences décisionnelles
pour connaître les 32 propositions
visant à l'équilibrage territoriale de
l'offre de soins consultez la synthèse
du rapport
[Musique]